>>> Ladies and gentlemen, good morning.
Would you please welcome Xavier Ducrohet and
Tor Norbye.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Good morning.
I'm Xavier Ducrohet.
>>Tor Norbye: And I'm Tor Norbye.
In this talk, we will show you what we have
been working on in the tools team over the
last year and give you sneak peaks coming
up.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Let's start with everyone's
favorite tool, the emulator.
We are well aware that there's been a lot
of problems, especially on the emulator running
larger configuration like tablet sizes, and
we have been working on fixing that.
Last year at I/O, I talked about a prototype
of hardware GL, and I'm very happy that finally
we released that a few months ago.
If you are running ICS and above and if you
are unable to (indiscernible) support the
AVD location dialogue, you will be able to
use your computer GPU to do the rendering.
The problem is that software rendering using
code that is being interpreted into X86 was
not fast enough for higher resolution.
So that helps for general interactivity in
the emulator, but that doesn't help if you
have an application that does a lot of computation.
To help with that, Intel contributed into
the OSP project support for virtualization
mode.
And so we already had that for Linux, but
they added support for Windows and for Mac.
They have released Jelly Bean system images
and ICS system images -- not Jelly Bean, Gingerbread
and ICS.
We are working for them for the Jelly Bean.
If you are using that, you will see the emulator
is much faster, and I'm going to give you
a quick demonstration in a little bit.
First, let's talk about hardware emulation.
We have had different strategies about supporting
hardware.
So since, basically, 1.0, we added telephony
support.
So to support telephony in the emulator, we
use another tool, DDMS, on the emulator and
allow you to allow to initiate code to send
code into the emulator.
About a year ago, we started really using,
actually, hardware to emulate hardware into
the emulator.
We started with webcam support.
If you have USB webcam or webcam directly
into your lap, you can input a video stream
into the emulator.
If you used the camera application, you would
see the output of your webcam.
Starting more recently, we decided that those
devices have a lot the hardware that you don't
find anywhere else.
Sensors, accelerometer, compass, gyroscopes,
multi-touch screens, you don't have that on
your random computer.
So we decided to start using that.
And so using a device tethered through USB
cable, we are starting to send some of that
information back into the emulator.
Let's see what that looks like.
So I have an emulator here.
This is running a regular 10-inch tablet screen,
1280 by 800.
It doesn't look great because it's a little
bit scaled so it fits on screen.
This is running ICS with GPU on and with X86.
The -- as you can see, it's very smooth.
If we go into all apps, there we go, it's
-- really follows very well your interactivity.
So I encourage you to try it.
It works very well.
So let's look at touch input.
As you can see, when I click somewhere, there's
a small white dot that you touch feedback.
And you can enable that in the settings if
you go into developer options.
So I have a phone here running a small application
that's packaged with the SDK so you can compile
it on application and then it can start swiping.
I'm not touching my laptop; I'm just touching
my phone.
[ Applause ]
>>Xavier Ducrohet: So doing that, with just
one touch, it's pretty easy, but -- yes, that's
okay.
I will do it that way.
It may rotate while I'm doing it.
We work to go disable that.
So that's the point your location in dev tools.
I can do two touches, three touches, four
touches, five touches, as many, really, as
your device will support.
A device like that will do ten touches.
I will try to put all of my fingers.
>>Tor Norbye: Good if you are developing a
ninja game.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: That would be perfect.
That's the emulator.
Our goal here is to let you try on any type
of form factor that you don't necessarily
own, and we don't expect you to buy every
device out there.
We really want you to be able to try your
application on the emulator no matter what
type of hardware your application is using.
We will work to improve even more the hardware
support.
So that means we want you to be able to create
emulators to really emulate any kind of devices.
To help you with that, we will show you something
I just started working on.
I have -- I forgot to clear that.
So this is the AVD creation manager.
AVD stands Android Virtual Device, really
a configuration of emulator to simulate a
particular device.
So, normally, you would enter an APL.
And we are going to -- we just added that
particular menu here, where you have a bunch
of devices.
And we're going to work with OEMs to make
sure that this is populated with as many devices
as we can.
So here, let's say you want to create an emulator
that emulates exactly Nexus 7 -- not that
any of you need that anymore.
So you click here and here, all the properties,
all the hardware is set up for you.
This is going to be exactly a Nexus 7, the
proper density, the proper resolution.
Like the resolution is entered here, and it
will be done for you.
[ Applause ]
>>Xavier Ducrohet: So I'm going to give you
the name.
Here I just created -- I started, but I'm
not going to do it.
So I have a second one since I already had
a first one.
One thing that we added was, you may have
noticed those generics devices, and those
were presented before in the emulator, so
since we are doing that, we figured that we
may as well also show you in the new editor.
When you choose a device here, we just show
you your AVD here directly.
When I chose the AVD I just created, since
we know it was created to match a Nexus 7,
then we just render it as if it was on a Nexus
7.
All right.
So that's the new editor, or part of it.
Why don't you tell us a bit more about that
editor.
>>Tor Norbye: Okay.
I'm going to defer the editor and start with
the basic editing we have improved over the
last year.
Hopefully, you all know, in Java files, in
Eclipse, you can press control O to open up
this quick outline and do quick filtering
to navigate to a method.
We made that work better in XML files now.
So if I'm, for example, in this layout file
and I'm looking for button 5, I can type B
log chart 5.
[ Applause ]
>>Tor Norbye: You can also use control shift
P to jump between matching tags.
We enhanced the code completion to work with
custom views.
This is particularly useful.
Let me show it.
Control space, you can see here we pick up
on the app name space.
We even find the documentation for your custom
style and show it to you.
Hopefully make that easier.
My favorite part, though, in the XML is the
new formatter.
If you look at this file here, this is what
you used to get when you reformatted the files
out of the box.
If I do this now, you can see I get a much
clearer layout.
[ Applause ]
>>Tor Norbye: And this is not just adjusting
indentation.
It's also, for example, reordering attributes.
So I put the height before the width and maybe
the ID down here, maybe mess up the indentation
a bit, too, you can see it puts things back
in the right order.
[ Applause ]
>>Tor Norbye: Not that Android cared what
the order is.
This is the style we recommend and we follow
in all of our tutorials.
And the other thing you see here, for layouts,
we prefer to have a blank line for the elements
and one attribute per line.
You can use your editors and set it up to
format the same way.
What's unique about this, if I switch to,
for example, a strings file, like this one,
and I press control shift F here, it does
something totally different.
Here we format the way string files should
be formatted, one string per line, unless
you are working with a Perl.
Of course, if I go to manifest file, there
are other heuristics which apply.
Hey, let's put the permissions in one block,
and let's treat the application element as
more like a layout tag.
So I don't type indentation anymore.
Instead of pressing the tab key, no matter
where I am, whatever I've copied or anything
like that, I press control shift F and it
puts things back in order.
The next thing I want to show you is the rebound
wizards.
So if I open up the new wizard, you can see
that we have a bunch of new items in this
list.
And the list is going to get longer, by the
way.
We mostly worked at infrastructure at this
point.
This is what the new project wizard looks
like now.
It's completely different, because it's been
rewritten.
And let's type in an application name.
Google I/O demo.
So notice that as I'm moving the focus between
these text fields.
On the bottom here, we have explanation.
For example, when we get to the package name,
please choose carefully.
You will have to stick with this package name
forever.
Likewise, we explain the difference between
the build target and the MSDK version.
We used to ask what number you want.
Now we are showing you code names and version
numbers and everything.
You also have the option of creating a custom
icon.
And that happens on the second page.
So this is the assets studio.
[ Applause ]
>>Tor Norbye: So here we can choose between
some clip art.
You can also start with random text.
So I can choose I/O. Maybe pick a different
shape.
Add some padding.
More likely, though, you will have some project
or company logo you want to use.
So you can go in and fetch that image.
So I'm going to put an I/O logo here and put
it in.
And as you can see, it's now going to create
different density versions of this icon, also
gives sort of a standard shading treatment.
[ Applause ]
>>Tor Norbye: So this is even more useful
when you're dealing with things like notification
icons and action bar icons.
And we're going to show that in a bit more
detail in the layout talk tomorrow.
So on a third page, I get to choose what to
put into the project.
We no longer create this empty project.
I can choose between a master detail flow
skeleton, which will create a tablet version
with details on the left -- right and a chooser
thing on the left, or I can create among a
set of blank activities.
So, by default, I can get tabs, I can get
swiping, I can get swiping plus title script.
[ Applause ]
>>Tor Norbye: Drop-down.
Sadly, right now, this requires Ice Cream
Sandwich.
But we are really hard at work at back porting
all this, and so ASAP, hopefully, this will
also generate compatibility codes.
Default layout, you see there it is.
Let me show you what happens when I add into
an existing project.
So I invoke the new wizard again.
Choose add activity, and I'm going to have
to choose a unique name.
When I hit "next" now, I get this preview.
Let me maximize it.
So you can see that what we are doing here
is, we are not just creating a new activity
class, we are adding registration into the
manifest.
We are adding resources into the string file.
[ Applause ]
>>Tor Norbye: And so forth.
So let's talk about the layout editor a bit.
So when you're editing layouts, you don't
really need to be spending your precious screen
real estate on the package explorer, output
window, and so forth.
Luckily, Eclipse supports the concept of maximizing
the editor, Control M, which is really useful
when you are editing Java code, but it's now
useful in the editor as when.
Press Control M. Not only do we get rid of
this other stuff, we also include a structure
view and property sheet inside the layout
editor now.
These are configurable.
I can, for example, drag the structure to
the bottom here.
This is useful if I'm trying to do a landscape
orientation like this.
I can also give myself more space by minimizing,
for example, the pallette.
Now that it sits over there, I can hover over
it, I can drag out the widget I need.
When I do that, it goes away and it gives
me the space I need to see my layout in.
The most important change is the property
sheet which has been completely revamped.
So you can see if I select something here,
first of all, if I hover, it will show me
the documentation for the property that I'm
about to edit.
If it's a Boolean property, I can click it
to cycle through the values true/false and
not set.
When you look at the properties here, you
can see where you might not be able to see
because this font is small.
Trust me, there's blue colors for things that
you have set.
And we're also showing inherited attributes
when possible.
So, for example -- it's okay.
You can clap.
You can see here the inherited color for text
link is blue.
And the way most property sheet implementations
work is they call the getter and ask what
is your color and they can display it.
In Android, we can't do that, because many
XML attributes don't have a corresponding
get every.
What we have done, what Java has done, we
intercept the value lookup.
That gives us something cool.
Which is, look, we can show you that this
is not just blue but this is actually the
resource Android color Holo blue lite.
Likewise, we
are showing these attributes in groups, so
you can see nesting here, text view attributes
are all together, and we are showing the important
properties in bold.
That's useful if you switch to an alphabetical
order.
If you are looking for a particular property
by name, you can switch that order.
And we're also hiding a lot of more attributes.
We ran statistics on code bases and found
there are attributes that are never set.
You can expose them if you want.
There are great italics properties here.
If I choose this edit text, you can see something
interesting.
We also preview drawables, so in edit text
has an actual attribute to set the icon that's
shown when you are selecting and it's right
there, you can see we are previewing it for
you.
Let's set some actual properties with this
property sheet.
So let me switch back from alphabetical order.
All right.
So hello Google I/O. And I'm going to set
the color.
Notice that we do complete completion on resources
which is kind of handy.
I'm going to set the size to 36, not bips,
but SPs.
And you can invoke customizers as well.
One other cool thing we have added is we showed
the resolve values.
If you look where I'm pointing at here, as
I'm selecting different resources, you can
see what the current resolve value of this
attribute is.
This works not just for dimensions but strings
as well.
That's a property sheet.
You can see that the -- we have these weird
guidelines in the layout editor here that's
because this is a relative layout.
Last year at I/O we previewed this layout
support.
Now it's basically done, and so if I'm dragging
in here, you can see we have been enhanced
it a bit more.
In addition to showing guidelines, we have
this tool tip which is trying to stay out
of the way for the constraints being shown.
But it shows me what it is it is displaying.
So this year we have a preview of another
layout that came out in Ice Cream Sandwich,
the grid layout.
We are trying to go for the same tools experience
that you have with relative layout.
As you are dragging, you get these guidelines.
We are trying to go one step further.
You can see these red lines.
This is something that appears in a lot of
the internal UI specs at Google.
This is a feature that is not done, and you
but we are working on it and bring it back
to the other layouts so you get the recommend
UI look for these things.
Let me show you fragment support.
I brought up the wrong layout.
So this is the Google I/O app, it is using
fragments.
The key thing about this layout is that this
is only organizing how these fragments will
appear.
It's relative to each other.
It's not controlling what's inside the fragment
at all.
That obviously is controlled by Java code
at run time.
So it could be different layouts showing up
depending on the context.
We give you a way at design time pick which
one it is to work with.
We basically look at the class, figure out
what layouts are you referring to and we offer
them here.
So you can see that in this layout, maybe
I want to show waiting for sync, here we have
some various banners shown at the bottom.
In the middle there's a ListView and on the
ride there's several options I'm going to
choose this one.
So you can see this is basically what this
app looks like when you run, but we can work
on editing the overall structure.
We can also go and edit the internals.
If I do the swipe select, you can see this
is the outer layout.
If you double click, I can go to the inner
fragment layout and edit just that.
I can go into the property sheets and change
the text to, for example, be patient, or something
like that.
Let's save and exit that.
Now, you can also work with new fragments
on your own.
It's pretty easy.
If I delete the fragment, now we have a normal
layout that you are familiar with.
The way you insert a fragment is to just go
the pallette, find the fragment tag and drag
it on to your layout.
We pop up this dialogue, which fragment class
do you want.
You can create a new one with the create new
on the bottom.
I will pick an existing one for now.
Choose something to show it design time and
there it is.
All right.
So the last thing I want to show in the layout
editor is the new configuration chooser.
So I've already shown you that you can flip
orientations very easily through the orientation
toggle.
You can obviously choose between other things
such as the UL mode and the night mode.
Xav showed you how to switch different screen
sizes to see how this looks in tablet size.
We also let you choose between themes here.
So we've ordered them so you can easily pick
the themes that you have defined in your project
with the themes you have in your manifest
or Holo themes or Holo lite themes.
This used to be a giant list.
Hopefully it's easier to work with now.
And we also have a new thing here.
This is the activities users.
So why would a layout have an associated activity?
We haven't needed it until now, but we're
starting to.
So right now we are using this to figure out
which theme to default your render with, because
in your manifest is where you're declaring
theme associations and that's based on the
manifest.
But in the next release, hopefully, we're
going to use this to also be able to render
your action bar items in line.
We will look at this associative activity
and render it there.
There might be other features as well.
Now, we also have a locale chooser.
So this shows you basically the locale to
have.
And we have flags as well.
This is based on a very simple heuristic mapping
from language to country flags so I hope there
are no obvious mistakes, I don't want to start
some kind of an international incident.
File a bug if you see something obviously
wrong.
And so obviously I can choose the language
here and we'll rerender with the other language.
And finally you can choose a different rendering
target to see what this looks like on a different
platform.
So everything I've shown you so far is in
AD20 which we shipped yesterday.
But now I'm about to show you something I'm
really excited about which is a new feature
that we're working on and this is something
we're calling multiconfiguration editing.
So I don't even know how to start so I'm just
going to show you.
I'm going to say generate the full thumbnails.
So what I did here was this is showing what
this layout is going to look like with a different
theme, in a different language, different
screen size, different orientation.
And the key part about this is if I edit this,
these guys are staying in sync.
[ Applause ]
>>Tor Norbye: And I can obviously switch between
them to see, you know, what does this look
like, I can go back.
I can zoom in on something, if I want to see
them, you know, in a larger dimension to see
what's going on.
And the key part about this also is that I
get to choose what these things are.
So if I'm, for example, really interested
in supporting French, because French is?
The best language, right, Xav?
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Yes.
I mean oui.
[ Applause ]
>>Tor Norbye: I should have gone for the Brazil
cheap shot but I didn't do that.
So I can now pick French and I can go add
a thumbnail and see, now, it's showing up
over here, showing me this in French, and
as I go back to the default, you can see this
one states showing me what this looks like
in French, I don't know if you can see that,
it might be tricky.
Give it some more room here.
So this is basically now showing me persistent
French preview.
All right.
So that's just -- we generated some default
thumbnails for you, you can also add your
own.
And we have some other ones.
Look at this, preview all screen sizes.
Let me get some more screen space.
This is showing the layout across all the
screen sizes that I care about.
[ Applause ]
>>Tor Norbye: And preview all locales.
So here we have a rendering of what this looks
like across a bunch of different languages.
And you can see that as I'm editing this,
these things immediately start rendering to
whatever the current layout looks like.
I can obviously -- I don't know if you can
tell, but something looks wrong, let me zoom
in a bit more so it's easier to see from your
perspective.
You can see that something looks wrong here.
Let me zoom in so you can see.
This button is too high compared to this one.
So I could obviously zoom in like this, or
we can switch to it, right, and we can see
what's going on.
So this feature I think is going to be immensely
useful.
You can basically make your edits and simultaneously
keep an eye on what this is going to look
like across screen sizes, languages, any configuration
language you care about.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: So one thing that's really
interesting here is that we show you a language,
but it's really the main configuration so
that if you switch to something else --
>>Tor Norbye: Yes, if I switch to a dark action
bar theme, it's now showing the dark action
bar theme in these other languages, and I
can switch orientation, it's now showing me
the other orientation, so, yeah, I think this
is going to be useful, so I'm really excited
about finishing it.
[ Applause ]
>>Tor Norbye: All right.
So the last thing I want to show you is Lint.
So you might have noticed as I've -- if you've
looked very carefully, you might have noticed
-- and if you're sitting near the front, you
might have noticed these little warning icons
showing up on top of the layout.
This thing.
What's that?
We have a new tool in the Android tools called
Lint which is basically a bug-checker.
It looks through your code, your Java files,
your XML files, your ping files, your -- even
your Proguard files and looks for errors and
it cross-correlates things to make sure there
aren't problems.
We look for correctness issues, usability
issues, performance issues.
Here's an example of a usability issue.
If I hover over this, you can see we get a
tool tip on the bottom, so we're always putting
the tool tips on the bottom, so they're not
on top of the layout, this could get really
old really quickly if we kept putting up tool
tips on top of your design.
This is showing that the bucking order is
wrong.
Since we're targeting AP14 or higher, the
okay button should be on the right.
So when I do that, the error goes away.
So we're actually running Lint incrementally
for every UI action on this layout.
If I add some more errors here, let's throw
in some buttons, for example, you can see
there's a counter up in the right here.
Does it look familiar?
So this one is basically incrementing and
showing you the -- when you have no errors,
it disappears, but it's saying I have two
issues now, and these are basically both -- there's
a hard-coded string here.
So we run Lint incrementally on every UI action,
we also run it on every save.
So if I'm in an XML file and I find a -- if
I were to, like, hard code this string here
and say cancel, the minute I hit save, you
see I get a warning where saying there's an
issue, you should use a string and resource
here.
This is not just for XML files.
If I switch to a Java file and let's go and
create a toast.
Toast dot -- c'mon, make text.
Context, hello, and one.
The minute I save, you can see it tells us,
did you forget to call show on this?
I don't know if anyone who's done this but
--
[ Applause ]
>>Tor Norbye: So we run Lint incrementally
when we can, but there are certain kinds of
checks that require global analysis, we can't
do it incrementally.
For example, finding unused resources.
That requires all declarations and all references.
So the way you run Lint on the whole project
is to go to the Toolbar where we have this
Lint action and I can run Lint on all projects
or just a particular project.
And when I do that, you can see -- we open
this window in the bottom here, Lint warnings,
and here we've collapsed it as much as possible.
I can expand it if I want, but we're showing
one item per type of issue.
And as I select these, you get a fuller description
because it's really hard to explain a problem
to a user in less than 80 characters.
So you can get the fuller explanation and
sometimes there's more information as well.
So let's take a look at some of these errors.
If I double click you can see we jump right
to it.
Here it's saying there's a problem where in
the XML we can jump to it, in XML this is
a button and that is not compatible with the
cast two toggle button, so it's cross-referencing
XML and Java.
Likewise, we have a string formatter called
here where we're passing a string as a second
formatting argument, and if we look at that
actual string, you can see that it's actually
supposed to be an integer.
Here's a good one --
[ Applause ]
>>Tor Norbye: Here's a call to set the text
color.
We're passing in the color black, this compiles
just fine.
So what's the problem?
Well, we're passing a resource ID, not the
actual RGB triplet.
These are just in, so it compiles just fine,
but it's a subtle problem so -- we found this
in our own code, too, as well, unfortunately.
In the keynote yesterday, you found out how
to increase the amount of butter in your diet.
We have some Lint checks her to help you sort
of avoid jitter.
So what you don't want to do unconditionally
allocate objects in any draw call or on measure
call, so we look for that, calling create
bitmap.
If you do put conditional logic around it
Lint should be quiet about it.
Now, in the summary here, you see light bulbs.
I don't know if you can see it, so I'm going
to zoom in again.
There's light bulbs next to some of these
warnings.
And this is basically telling you we have
an automatic quick fix for it.
For example, it says here that this text field
does not specify input type or hint.
I can either press the fix icon here or I
can use a quick fix while I'm editing.
And we have explanation of the issue.
I've run the quick fix and it inserts, you
know, the correct fix.
I hit control shift F to just clean things
up again.
The other thing I can do is suppress issues.
So let's say that I don't care about hard-coded
text because I only want to support French.
Yes!
Do you see a theme here?
If I invoke control one to invoke the quick
fix, there's actually and add ignore hard-coded
to element here.
This let's me suppress this issue.
So if I select this you can se it actually
adds an ignore element on the specific type
of issue, this can also say all or be a common
separate list of things I don't care about.
And I can move this attribute up to the root
if I wanted to suppress it for the whole file.
So the tools name space is special.
This was something that was added I think
in tools 18.
And this is basically going to be ignored
by AAPT.
So anything in this name space, there's no
penalty whatsoever.
It does not make it into the APK.
But it's great for us.
We can store metadata this way now, not using
comments like we used to.
So the ability to suppress errors is not just
for XML files.
If I go over to a Java file, I can do the
same thing there.
So if invoke control one, I have a bunch of
suppressed Lints and this is using annotations.
All right.
So I want to show one more thing here.
I assume many of you are trying to target
not just the very latest version of Android
and so you always have a choice.
Do you want to build your app against the
oldest platform you're supporting?
That's good because it means you're not going
to accidentally use any APIs that aren't supported
everywhere, but it's bad because you have
to access reflection to access anything newer
and that's really cumbersome.
The other choice is to compile against the
very latest version of the Android SDK, the
problem then is that what if you accidently
use an API that isn't supported, you're going
to have a runtime error.
So we now have a solution for that with Lint
which basically lets you have the best of
both worlds.
Now you should compile against the latest
target and then Lint will tell you when you
have some kind of a illegal API reference.
So I'm going to show that here by calling
get action bar and we'll assign it to this.
All right, let me save -- okay.
So now, after I saved, it's coming up with
an error and it's saying that this class requires
API 11 and that this method call here requires
API 11.
And we're trying to target five.
So the error message says exactly what the
problem is.
And so you can basically make sure that this
code is then only called on a path that is
guarded with some kind of a version check.
And once you've done that, you can say I know
this class will only be called when we know
the API is 11 so I can use the new target
API annotation to basically mark this as being
clean for Lint.
The last thing I want to show you is a preview
of a new Lint check that we're working on.
So I'm going to open up the Lint preferences
dialogue.
This is showing all the Lint errors.
So we have about 100 of them right now that
we're checking, and this is increasing in
every release, so make sure you keep updating.
In this build I have a special -- special
Lint check which is disabled by default but
I'm going to enable it now.
This is called missing permission.
So I'm now going to go into this class again
and I'm going to innocently create a new socket.
All right.
So I've got to fix the import.
And now I get a new warning here saying this
requires Internet permission, which I don't
have.
So if I, then, go to the Lint window and say,
you know, fix this, it will open up the manifest
file and add the Internet permission for me
and this checks all the libraries I'm using
as well.
[ Applause ]
>>Tor Norbye: So that check does, however,
require a really good permission database
which we're working on.
So this is not going to be out in the next
couple months, it's a little bit longer term
goal, but I hope this will be useful.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Excellent.
Thank you, Tor.
All right, let's talk a little bit about developing
tools.
So in 20 that we just released yesterday,
we added a few new tools.
The first one that we added is a tool called
tracer for OpenGL ES, and as its name indicates,
it's going to help you trace your OpenGL codes,
so it's useful if you're using an engine that's
doing GL code for you and you don't know exactly
what's going on.
It's working on Jelly Bean and only on devices,
I don't think it works on emulator.
And it's available as an Eclipse plug-in and
it's available as a standalone application.
Now the standalone application, when we developed
it, we realized that we were starting to have
quite a few standard applications.
DDMS, Traceview, (indiscernible) some are
the UI are kind of crappy.
None of them were configurable, let's say.
So we decided to just revamp that and integrate
all of them into a single application.
We are basing that on the plug-ins that we
have for Eclipse, so we use and LCP-based
application that's the Eclipse rich client
platform, so that you can figure out the windows
to look like you want them to look, so it
will be much better.
The second tool that we're adding which we
actually showed very quickly at the keynote
yesterday, Systrace.
This is a very low-level tracing tool, and
I will show you output and show you a few
things in there.
And then the third thing that we are adding
is the first bit (indiscernible) of the NDK
support in Eclipse.
So we have support for building.
So as you edit your JNI code it automatically
get compiled and put in the right place.
And we have debugging support so you have
a launch configuration, and we start you to
be on the device, we do all the things, and
then if you have a break point, we just stop
on there.
Let's do a quick demo of -- so my SDK here.
So the monitor, the Android device monitor
which is the tool that regroups everything
is under tools, it's called monitor.
We still have the other ways, so as we transition,
we will remove the other ones.
But DDMS is still there, Trace is still there.
We have a nice splash screen.
>>Tor Norbye: Thanks, Romain.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Yes.
There we go.
That's not what I wanted but, well, let's
show it again.
Okay, so this is -- so you have the DDMS here.
There we go.
So it looks like the DDMS that you may already
be using except that if you really don't care
about the monitor control you can just go
in, close it, you can move things around.
So if you have ever used Eclipse it's basically
the same view system.
And then, you know, we have some utilities
in there that you should look at, we have
like the network statistics.
I think Jeff Sharkey is doing a demo where
he will show that so you should definitely
try to see that.
And then here, on the top right, you have
the different tools so the (indiscernible)
is here and then the tracer for OpenGL ES
is here.
So I have -- see my device here?
And I'm going to start tracing a tool.
So the way the tool works is that it's meant
to work on any chips that are out there.
There are some GL debugger currently available
but they are generally tied to a particular
chip set.
So we wanted to do something that would work
on any devices so that whatever devices you
have, that will work.
This works whether you're using Java bindings
or whether you're using [NATPIs, it's just
above the driver in the GL library.
And what we do is intercept every code that
is done to the driver and then we start building,
you know, a separate state.
Because of that and because we can't query
the driver to actually get information about
the context, we have to basically start the
application in a certain way.
So if you have an application that's already
started, you have to quit it and then start
it again.
so you click here.
And then -- so here I'm going to start the
settings application.
You can select your device here.
Which application.
If you want to start a particular activity,
you can do that, too.
And then here you have a couple options.
So by default, we're going to get every GL
code that you're doing but sometime you actually
want to see what you're drawing.
So that -- those check boxes are for you to
choose what you want us to gather for you.
By default, really, you want to get the result
of each frame so what happened after a swap
buffer.
In some cases you want to see the results
of every GL draw that's going to be significantly
slower because we have to send them back from
the device on to the application.
So I recommend not doing them all the time,
there's another way after, and then you decide
where you're going to send the trace file.
So let's trace a very simple session into
the sending app.
So I'm going to click trace.
There I go.
So I'm going to start tracing.
You can see that's it's starting to collect
frame.
And as I said earlier, if you want to get
the result of every GL draw, just before you
do an action, enable it here, then do your
action and then stop it.
So I probably have enough data to show you
that.
So let's stop tracing.
And let's open it.
Stop.
Here.
Okay.
Let's see.
So what you have here, at the top you have
the actual frames.
So if we look here, you have the actual drawing
of the frame, normally.
There we go.
So this is what was drawn by the application.
And as I scroll, we should start seeing the
-- basically scrolling through the sending
application.
Here, before that you actually have the construction
of each frames.
So every -- you start with the GL view port,
and then you -- and all the way at the end
with a swap buffer.
And through all those codes you can look at
your GL context here, everything that's in
blue means it's what changed from one code
to another.
So if I start here and I change, you'll see
what change on every code, which, you know
-- and then you can also go look at something,
for example, I just organized that over here,
since we can.
You can see your shader, you can see your
vertex, you can see your textures, you know,
everything.
You can also do this.
There we go.
You can do search.
So one thing that you've seen -- oh, it's
collapsed.
There we go.
So one thing that you may have noticed is
there's some kind of ER key going on.
So we added some extension to GL, the first
one is you can put a marker with a particular
string and then will show up here.
So if you want to say, hey, I'm starting to
do that and I'm done doing that, you put two
markers and then you can search on that and
see it.
And the other option is to actually push and
pump to and from a stack.
So this is what happens here.
This is the regular view framework.
It's rendering with GL.
So every time it unshows a new view group
it says, hey, I'm (indiscernible) out, so
it does a push and then every children say,
I'm a text view, I'm a button, whatever, and
then when they stop drawing, then pops from
the stack and then they would will show up
here.
So if you have your own game engine or anything
like that and you want to start doing some
ER key display here, you can definitely do
those extensions.
So that is GL tracer.
The next tool that I want to show you is the
output of trace.
So we showed it briefly during the keynote.
I'm just going to show you a very quick demo.
Romain and Chet Haase will actually do a more
in-depth look at the session at 2:45, I believe,
today.
So I encourage you to go see that.
So it's a system-level trace.
You can see everything that happens on your
CPU.
You can see, you know, the binder thread for
interprocess communication.
You can see the Vsync.
You can see everything.
It's very loadable, and it can really get
stuff into a lot of details.
So if you look here, I'm showing about five
seconds, and then you can start zooming into
things and see really what happens all the
way down to very, like, short events.
Like this event here, whatever that was, 4.0.6
millisecond.
So you can take on any blocks of color just
exactly -- what am I doing here?
So exactly what was going on, what it was,
how long it took.
You can do selection to see exactly what happened
somewhere to see the emulator and the speed.
>>Tor Norbye: If you have some sort of jitter,
you want to use this to figure out why.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Traceview is there.
If you want to see what happens at the system
level, Systrace is the way to do it.
Okay.
Let's talk a little bit about Android projects.
So you're creating a complex application.
Every time I talk to a developer, I'm always
amazed by what you are doing.
You are using 20 library projects.
I have a hundred jars or something like that.
You are pushing the system to the limit.
We really want to help you.
We know that you want to share code and resources
across different applications or different
-- across the same version of the same application.
It's just, you know, very complicated.
One thing we do want to do is make sure that
Eclipse and Ant work seamlessly.
Our approach is you live in the ID.
We do Eclipse but IntelliJ, why not, any other
tool.
You can use the great feature that Tor showed
you today.
If you do configuration, add dependency and
put it on your brief server, you shouldn't
have to maintain two different projects.
That's one of the things we are trying to
do.
So how do you share code and resources?
So we kind of have three ways of doing that
right now.
The first way is by using Java Project in
Eclipse.
It's really a shortcut to cross -- shortcut
for generating a Java file and putting that
in another project.
It doesn't work in Ant.
You could do custom work in Ant.
I would recommend against using that.
But if you want to, it's up to you.
Library project; so this is something that
we introduced a while ago and we are definitely
committed to doing this.
This is the right way of sharing code and
resources across Android applications.
It's still available in source compile time
version.
We are working on a binary distribution for
that.
We are starting to see exactly what we need
to do there.
Other systems like support some binary application.
You can use (indiscernible), and then the
third one is Java.
Java is easy.
You go online, run a source library that does
what you want.
You download, put Java in your project, you're
done.
That works great when you have a small project.
When you have a bigger project with lots of
libraries and Java, you can get into some
serious problems.
Let's look at an example here.
Let's say you have an application.
You have three library projects and each of
them actually use a jar file.
As a human, I need the V2 version of the library
because the other one is redundant.
The system doesn't work that way.
The previous version was very stupid.
It would take all three versions of the jar
file.
Each of those library have a copy of that
So each would actually send all three versions
of the jar to the DX tool which convert into
the byte code.
It would process the first jar file, the second
one.
On the first class of that jar, it would complain
saying, hey, I already know about this class
and then it will break.
I'm sure you've seen "this class already added"
error.
So this is a very simple example.
Very quickly, if you add more library, if
you have a jar file that will bring other
dependencies, it gets complex very quickly.
The right way of doing that is to -- fixing
that is to have a real dependency management
system, like Maven or OIV.
We definitely want to get there.
We are not there at the moment.
We are working on it.
We do want great ID support.
We are still looking at what we are going
to do.
In the meantime, we do want to help you with
the most common use case.
So a couple of months ago we released an update
that would support the case where, let's say,
you have two library projects and in each
of them you have a jar file support library,
and you want that to work.
We introduced a very simple conflict resolution
system.
Something like Maven will identify the jar
file by artifact ID version and a clear understanding
of what a library is, what a jar file is.
Here we don't really have that information.
We have the file.
So we just purely base that on file name.
If you have plenty of library projects, all
of them have the support library, we are going
to identify all the duplicates of Android.
We are going to make sure they are all the
same exact file.
By that I don't mean like the version because
we don't know about that.
We just compare the file itself.
If they are all the same, that's great.
We just pick one of them randomly and then
we just discard all the rest and basically
get rid of duplicates.
If you -- if we find a file that's different,
then we are going to actually generate an
error.
Typically in this case, you have two library
projects.
You get the newer version of the library support
we used yesterday but only completing one
of those projects.
You are completing both but you submitted
only one of the get project and not the other
one and then your co-worker complains, that
kind of thing.
We detect that.
We did add a very simple custom support for
the library support actually because the V13
version actually embeds the V4 inside.
If we were using something like Maven, we
would not have the V4 inside.
We say that depends on V4.
Right now, this contains it.
So if we took V4 and V13, we drop V4 and just
use V13.
So as I said, this is very basic.
We really want to get you a really good build
system that will do a better dependency management
for you.
And this is a very high priority.
We are just not there yet.
So on the implementation side, in Eclipse
you have to reference every jar file into
your project, and so it would be even worse
than that.
If a library project -- say I use that jar
file and you had 20 applications using that
library project, you would have to go in all
of those 20 applications and manually also
add that jar file.
In Ant, you just drop it into the (indiscernible)
folder and it works.
We wanted to simplify that and make that the
same way for Eclipse also.
This is what you are doing now.
If you are manually referencing jar project
into Eclipse, don't.
Stop doing it.
Just drop them into the libs folder.
Many say lib without an s, so just libs, and
then we will automatically pick the right
one.
We have a dynamic container on the Eclipse
side, an Eclipse way of having a class pass
container that is dynamically filed by (indiscernible).
We do the resolution.
We drop duplicate, and we just put what the
application needs and we pick up whatever
is coming through the library project as well.
So we just grab everything that your application
needs.
So that was released a couple of months ago
in 17.
When we did that, we completely followed that
dynamic container preventing from you actually
doing source attachment.
This is really silly, but you can't.
And we could fix the UI to do it, but really
the registration is to make sure that wherever
you have a jar, you have a source attachment
specific to that jar.
So that if you have five applications using
the same library project that depends on a
jar file, you don't have to do the source
attachment on all five applications.
Again, if you had a dependency management
system, you wouldn't have that problem, because
part of your dependency would know where the
source is.
In the meantime, we have a very simple solution.
It looks like a bit of a hack, I'll admit,
but it works.
So if you have foo.jar properties.
Create those properties in there linking to
the source command and it will be picked up
automatically for you.
So library project, more improvements.
We have merging of manifest now.
So before if you had an activity that was
declared in a library, it wouldn't be picked
up by the application, even if you put it
in the manifest.
So we do have that now.
We will merge things like permissions, activities,
services, things like that.
It's basic.
If you have a conflict, it will fail.
We are working on adding that, being able
to say ignore, you know.
I know that library declared that permission.
I don't want it, I don't want that activity.
We are working on that kind of thing.
Because of that, it is not enabled by default.
If you want to try it in your project properties,
declare manifest merger.enabled and true and
it will be enabled for you.
[ Applause ]
>>Xavier Ducrohet: In 17 we also introduced
buildconfig.java.
It's very basic.
It declares a Boolean that is true.
So in Eclipse if you do an export, otherwise
it's debug and then in Ant it's depending
on if you do Ant release.
The one basic one we decided to introduce,
that for is this one.
Please stop logging too much information.
The log buffer is shared across all applications.
Especially don't log information that is just
sensitive, put that -- when we compile a release,
we ifelse, and the Java Compiler will discount
that code.
You can use that also for whatever else you
want.
This is one important use case.
Finally, we have made a lot of improvement
to Proguard.
We have linked the current rules.
What we did is we used to only be able to
reference one single Proguard file into your
project.properties.
We changed that to be able to reference more
than one file.
And we provide a default for into the SDK
folder and you can reference to it using the
sdk.gear property.
So now you can have your own word file that
Google will never touch.
Whenever we do an Android update project we
have never (indiscernible) your changes, and
then we can safely improve the Proguard rule.
I think people have obsolete files because
of that.
We have to optimize and non-optimize.
We provide those to you depending on which
version, to choose which one you want.
Another thing that we did is we used to be
able to be very conservative about removing
classes, another rule five that we use, and
so we know exactly when I XML files are being
used.
We are much more interested in removing classes.
If you use something like the support library
for just one particular small item that you
want, everything else will get removed for
you and you will get a much smaller application.
[ Applause ]
>>Xavier Ducrohet: All right, Lint.
>>Tor Norbye: We already talked about this.
We had a different order earlier.
I will show a couple other things regarding
Lint.
This is my window.
So Lint is -- I showed it running in Eclipse,
but it does not require Eclipse.
IntelliJ has integrated Lint as well, and
you can run on the command line.
If I go in here, type Lint, I talk point to
a particular project -- one directly.
It basically just runs through the code and
spits out the errors.
This is not a very useful format, so it actually
has several other formats.
I can pick a particular file name like that,
and when it runs it now, it creates a report
that I can then open.
So when I do that, I get something likes this,
which is basically -- it's showing the same
errors I explained to you but a bit more readable.
We include the descriptions.
We inlined -- for example in the case of mismatched
string format, you can see both cases of the
source inline right here.
This is useful.
[ Applause ]
>>Tor Norbye: Thank you.
The main use case for this is that even though
you can run Lint during your development,
you really want to run it continuously on
a server along with your unit tests, right?
So I hope that you are familiar with Jenkins
which is a continuous integration server.
Someone has contributed a Lint integration
for Jenkins.
This is the AOSP project.
If you look here, you can see this trend graph
showing the number of Lint warnings currently
around 1200.
Luckily there aren't very many red ones.
We can drill into this and take a look at
them.
So this is basically showing all the different
folders.
We can swatch back category as well.
So here we have a folder that has a red error,
and I can drill in to look at it.
We can see -- actually, what is this one?
Missing translation.
I saw a worse one earlier.
I guess I picked a different one.
This is the one I think I was going to look
at.
Correct.
Yes.
So here we have -- someone has used an underscore
instead of a colon in their attribute.
This is Lint running on the current sample
that we are shipping with AOSP.
So we have a bit of a cleanup job to do.
Let me quickly show you how this is set up.
If you go to configure, all I have done is
add these two commands here.
It basically, like I showed you, you can do
dash dash html report.
You can also emit XML reports.
That's what the plug-in is using.
That's basically how you set up Lint running
so you can basically blame people when they
increase the error count.
At the fireside yesterday someone asked, well,
can I add my own Lint rules?
The answer is, yes, you can.
It's actually pretty easy.
I will very briefly show you how to do that.
So the use case for this will be, let's say,
in your company you have a custom view.
There is some attribute that is always set.
So to do this, you need two classes.
Where did you put them?
Okay.
Two classes.
Issue registry, which is as simple as this:
Register this issue, and the detector class
which basically has a description, ID, summary,
and we tell Lint, hey, these are the elements
I relate to.
This is my custom view, and when you hit this
element, check that it has the attribute.
The way you do this is, you build this file.
You get this custom Lint jar file.
You copy that to your .Android Lint folder,
now when I run Lint, it is showing the error,
showing the detector that it is added.
So I can now run Lint.
I can check the specific issue on this project.
It should now emit the warning that we had
in this detector.
This is pretty simple.
The API is evolving, but it can be done for
today.
That's it for Lint for me.
[ Applause ]
>>Xavier Ducrohet: All right, so that was
it for demonstration.
A quick information about our team.
We work directly in OSP.
If you want to see what we are doing, Tor
should do some things that are coming, you
can go and get it and try it.
We have a tools site where we are regularly
posting information and sometimes we post
previews, also.
So we encourage you to try it and give us
feedback and then if you have questions, if
you want to help us, to contribute, the list
is there.
You can find us on Google+ also.
And we have two minutes and a half for questions.
There's two mics.
If you want, we'll be at the office hours
right after.
If you have any question, we'd be happy to
answer.
[ Applause ]
>>> So I had a question about relative layout,
and I use it a lot.
It's very useful.
However, when I start to refactor elements,
it messes up orientation because it doesn't
refactor IDs and other elements.
>>Tor Norbye: I guess I should go and look
at that.
Would you mind filing a debug, put the details
for how to reproduce it.
Any other questions?
>>> Yes, I'm working on a project right now
where I have five APKs at once and probably
more in the future and some libraries.
Is there anything you can say for multi-APK
support.
I have all these bass scripts and Ant in four
loops, it's getting really clunky.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Like building all of them
at the same time?
>>> Any suggestions for making my life easier.
I have a four-loop with all these Ant scripts
in it.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Seems like a good fix.
>>> I'm working on a project right now, I
have five APKs at once, and probably more
in the future, and some libraries.
Is there anything you can say for multi-APK
support, because I just got all these, like,
bash scripts with, like, Ant in four loops
right now, and it's getting really funky.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: You mean like building
all of them at the same time?
>>> Any suggestions for making my life easier?
Because I've got a four loop with, like, all
these Ant scripts in it.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Seems like a good fix.
I mean, we don't really have a project set
up for that.
So any kind of automation, you know, a batch
file, another Ant script.
If you have five of them, I think another
Ant script that calls your other Ant script
might be better than doing some batch magic.
But that's up to you really.
We don't really have anything.
>>> Okay.
Thank you.
You could put it in line for the future.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Yes.
>>> I've noticed that you've kind of been
slowly ramping up support for go to definition
to layout files and, like, string definitions
from within the code, as opposed to actually
just going to the R object, the
generated object --
>>> Yes.
>>> -- definition.
And I was just wondering, it seems like I
kind of don't know where -- like, when that's
implemented and when it's not implemented.
It would be nice if I could always hit F3
and go to the in-code definition.
Are you planning to, like, continue to support
more types of go to definition?
Or what's the plan with that?
>>Tor Norbye: Right now, in Java files, it
will always go to the R file.
And the reason for that is that we don't have
a way to actually give our resolver higher
priority than the built-in Java one.
So that's kind of how it works.
>>> That's an Eclipse thing?
>>Tor Norbye: It's Eclipse, yeah.
We don't have the option to sort of say, hey,
ours is more important than the Java one.
Because when you jump from, you know, our
definition to an actual field, that's the
Java one.
Going to the XML files, that's ours.
And we don't have a way to say ours is more
important.
Let us come in first.
>>> But it is in some places implemented from
the XML files; right?
>>Tor Norbye: Yes, from XML, yeah.
Those should always do the right thing.
If they don't, please file a bug.
>>> I don't think they work for strings.
But I might have just not checked --
>>Tor Norbye: They're supposed to.
So if they don't -- what they didn't work
for and which recently was fixed and I didn't
have time to show it, but is, they should
now work for theme references.
So the question mark thing that didn't used
to work, it should now.
>>> Okay.
Cool.
Thanks.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: We're running out of time.
As we said, we'll be at the office hours on
the third floor over there.
Feel free to come and ask us questions.
We will be happy to talk to you.
Thank you.